cela promet une belle journée pour les
scorpions culture à présent le ministre
de la culture stephan born propose de
faire classer au patrimoine de l'unesco
tout lé château ayant appartenu à des
rois de france mais déclare ce par tous
suivez-moi
[Musique]
la gueuse ses alliés nord pour toi que
tu veux je voulais savoir si c'était la
prof qui venait de claquer la porte si
élégamment à ton avis a peut être qui
d'autre j'ai pas le droit de sortir
parce que nenad l'ange fait peur aux
gens mais évidemment tu le sosie de la
prof
alors c'est les voisins te vois sortir
en costume du 15e siècle et sursautait
la moindre voiture
il est normal qu'il se pose des
questions je connais les voitures juste
pas prête pour les tracteurs et puis tu
le ressens pas aussi toi peut-être pas
fait de bien meilleures cheveux
bref si nous pouvions laisser cette
histoire de côté il faut qu'on parle
[Musique]
alors tu veux quoi c'est encore peu
parler d'hygiène je te rappelle que les
gens mon époque sont très propres c'est
à la renaissance seul j'en écoute je
veux enterrer le pilote de guerre est ce
que tu te souviens de commenter arrivé
ici ton attitude désinvolte et frivole
me laisse penser que non mais bon
sait-on jamais c'est vachement doué pour
faire la paix tu sais je m'en souviens
pas j'ai juste apparaît ici comme toi et
crois moi j'étais mieux quand t'étais
pas là mais tu dois bien avoir quelque
chose en tête
un dernier souvenir tiens raconte moi ce
que tu faisais avant d'arriver à moi que
ça aussi s'était échappé
ça je sais j'étais à la cueillette aux
champignons
un mental énorme
[Musique]
certes francs que faites vous ici
j'entraîne les faucons du duc je ne vois
pas de faucon il vole début de
l'exercice
mais que me vends votre présence en ces
lieux je cueille des champignons c'est
la saison soit je vais vous laisser
vaquer à vos occupations mais soyez
prudents et fermez bien votre cas la
forêt
oui merci
[Musique]
ce ne doit pas être la saison y'a
quelqu'un se côtoient et après le trou
noir
je me suis retrouvé dans la chambre de
la prof et toujours pas de champignons
l'étrange mais j'étais sûr que c'était
la saison mais pas sa diotte je veux
dire il est étrange que tu ne te
souviennes pas des circonstances qui
l'ont amenée ici alors que j'en ai un
souvenir très exact sans doute un défaut
lié à ton manque de croissance ralentit
c'est pourquoi on est ici ici
précisément non mais une autre fois
c'est promis
[Musique]